الحرب الاوكرانيه وصلت لنقطه فاصله هكذا
يرى حلف الناتو الوضع وهكذا يشير الواقع
على الارض روسيا تواصل التقدم والهجمات
الناجحات تستهلها بقيادته باليريج رامو
للعمليات اليوم سيطرت على مدينه كيليشيسكا
بالقرب من محمود افي دنياز وعلى اربع
مناطق في مقاطعه قبل ايام سيطرت على بلده
سول قبلها اعلن وزير الدفاع وانه سينفذ
توجيهات بوتن لاجراء اصلاحات عسكريه واسعه
النطاق بين 2003
و 2026 والهدف توسيع القوات المسلحه
الروسيه على الارجاح استعدادا اللي حربا
طويله الامل في اوكرانيا
الاصلاحات تشمل زياده عدد الافراد
العسكريين الروس الى مليون ونصف المليون
جندي من مليون
و350,000 في الحال حاليا وامام للحقائق
باتت زياده الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا ضروريه
ولذلك اجتمع وزراء ودفاع حلف الناتو في
قاعده رامشتاين في المانيا واوكرانيا التي
اعلنت التاهب الجوي في جميع انحاء البلاد
طالبه الغرب بالمزيد من الاسلحه تحديدا
الدبابات وسنتطرق لذلك لاحقا يرد وزير
الدفاع الامريكي
هذه مرحله حاسمه لاوكرانيا ومرحله صعبه من
الحرب نحن جميعا ندعم دفاع اوكرانيا عن
اراضيها مهما ترى الامر وسنحافظ على زخم
المساعدات العسكريه الاوكرانيا نعلم ان
روسيا مستمر في اعتداءتها وازادت من كثافه
هجماتها الصاروخيه التي طالت ارواح
الابرياء الاوكران وشاهدنا وحشيه ذلك قبل
ايام في مدينه نيبرو